[Music]
this week we got cookie in that Bell
robbers get away Tiffany ku steal
cookies
I thought you ready Fukui Oh complete
all Kukui master yeah I thought my uncle
ice to come through food
did you say mail rompers or mail robbers
robbers rompers I forgot one Oh cute
it's not one mechanically first let's
talk about cookie piece here so this
chick 26 years old her name is Julia I
like that name Lee actually told you she
saw twenty six thousand dollars worth of
Girl Scout cookies how from wait wait
wait I understand because those cookies
are ball let's talk about this dough can
we see a picture of this fat [ __ ] where
she ain't that and why is it started off
with a good feeling from kids oh she
said yeah and she's 510
who the [ __ ] decorated that police
station while their badges in between
the height no that's a mugshot branding
is brand-new we know what a [ __ ] you all
you already know that any time you see
that - you already know yes what county
now because of that you know what County
what counties up yeah I can't see this
far exactly
she has that face like yeah ate it Alan
yeah ate it I'm sorry $26,000 a
[ __ ] closer did she eat it all
each box is worth ah yah me I will say
this every time I see a girl go couple
kinky
[ __ ] you everyone will be center-right
hurt I get a good coffee [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] like um I don't have
that big of a sweet tooth
[ __ ] into this [ __ ] fell on us because
I'm using white so does the flip-flop
I'm used to having it in between my toes
so feels nice
anyway yo I thought about some serious
right now what about another thing those
little [ __ ] cute [ __ ] like I don't
have that big of a sweet tooth but I do
like the Samoas that's my favorite one
when I was out at the Safeway in my
neighborhood I bought a box and a little
girl with sight thank you sir so much
like YouTube [ __ ] give me one of each I
got all of this she was like oh my god
mommy's boy will not home go ahead and
thank the gentleman hops Tippi old what
a whole [ __ ] ton and I gave to Muriel to
give it to her of office please [ __ ]
two little girls dude goddamn it they
get you do dr. cookie kind of connected
the kukup okay yeah so this girl
actually on the run for some time I'm
not sure she got the cookie she was on
the run so was she the troop leader yeah
she was one of the troop leaders what
what ended up happening did she just
pocket the money or does she just eat
all the cookies so they're still looking
into what they didn't what she'd is
probably a double they don't know yet
they do it she's creating a [ __ ]
crazy-ass plot maze where it's like you
have five hours to find a quickie before
to get destroyed Oh some [ __ ] hunt
now and then they just have to follow
the crumb trail of all the cookies
mm-hmm they got this new [ __ ] too
actually I don't know if it's new we got
new flavor it's like a lemon flavored
one that my answer is it that's just
[ __ ] good I like a peanut butter one
to that comment area but they do have a
new flavor though I don't know which one
it is though my agent side making me do
some math right now so she stole $26,000
right 26 I'm not playing on my dick so
$26,000 worth the cookies right and it's
five bucks a box yet so that means it's
5200 boxes
I believe she ate it all look
a lot of cookies to consume 5200 boxes
how many cookies is in a box like good
like what would she do if she was like
flipping it for profits like she would
be like little girl scout and she sets
up her own stead
listen whole dollars look more what are
they like maybe she collected all the
money and then she didn't report it well
they're reporting is that she went to
multiple cookie cupboard where they keep
the cupboards as cute
yeah and in multiple counties and that's
like worse that's how she was able to
get away with it for some time I didn't
notice that she was getting so many
cookies because she's going to multiple
counties oh maybe she was eating it then
because it was not all at once so over
time she ate 5200 boxes were Lunas is
she good I think she ate them all look
there's evidence the song that was that
cookie song that we sing as a kid who
stole the cookie cookie jar hmm
what the [ __ ] is with the rest of it
Doug I've never heard I did Mon Ami you
cookie jar I remember it was kind of
like that I could like use a little no I
remember that we kind of like that the
country Thomas go get chopped fish
alright for our next story the internet
has been going wild if these mail
rompers I don't know I hate the pictures
of the mail robbers you don't want to
know the thing about the jingle but the
well rock was this let me see you guys
know promo video that was on the
Kickstarter page I don't know how I feel
you need a Kickstarter from the robbers
I understand that we can get money here
we go just got to take a blanket and cut
it up
well the Sun is fossa is that a college
on May 15 2017 aced design will
introduce the original Rompin and you'll
see that funny car is about to get
ruined this is a terrible video so
where's the romper they're they're
wearing it everyone every man in this
video dreaming oh I thought he just had
a I thought they were wearing boxer
shorts and a collar t-shirt
dude this is like an old like a JK skin
or something good I wanted to be yeah it
just looks like a mechanic's jumpsuit
but with shorts this here this is for
real this is a real all things
it's called Rompin wrong Tim I mean I
think I would invest in it if they at
least put a different color on the
bottom half so I can keep the pink and
then you put like I think they're trying
to emphasize the wrong team though I
know the girls rompers are all one too I
know but this guys can't rock it like
this yeah I'm looking at all my god that
means that you do got to get all but
make it to when they take you oh my god
so a big if I go to the bathroom with
one of these guys and I they have to go
peepee
dental stone I'm going to see a
shirtless dude with pants around his
thighs pink no I think I think it goes
all the way down yeah I think it goes
all the way down this well [ __ ] in the
blackboard I think it looks crazy but I
feel like I know the type of guy that
would buy that that could sell it going
good yes
like the coachella going guys the Vegas
club pool party going by I think it
would I think I think it's West
Hollywood guys just I think it's going
to be rich rich white yacht boys yeah
where it's going to be a rappers talk to
the other that yes I can see like
Sperrys going well with that you know
like if you got like some white boat
shoes and the other white big frame
glasses or something I could see it
going well but then you have to walk
around saying listen dude I'm just a
huge douche like that's amazing which
that's the message it gives off yeah
just a little bit just a tad I feel like
what's missing from this romper is a
hole in the butthole that is actually
for $10,000 that was their goal no no we
hope I guess what we're there are 50 a
million three hundred thousand you guys
fifty thirty thousand to fifty so people
really the closest to ten to forty yeah
fifty maybe they think it's really cool
yeah like a lot of people are digging
this outrage Coachella dude oh and then
the Vegas pool party dudes for sure and
they would get it because you know um I
actually liked jumpsuits I wore when
jumpsuits are kind of in I had a Dickies
jumpsuit yeah a Larsen's I understood
you know who should wear these no
rappers though that people fan people
that people what our fan people I don't
know how to clarify can I just read
written like like a like a me wearing
this it's not gonna work out I picture
it - it's pretty funny I've been
searchin I don't think so I think I
would look like a bag of sweet onions
just like a little Baldy I think you
have to be like feeling like that very
good in action look I do look good like
if you ate a tic tac you know stomach or
a buff guy wouldn't look good in it yeah
can you imagine a really muscular buff
guy in a romper that's just imagine part
of the rips that's gonna tear I want to
see all of you guys in one oh where was
robbery sent us Rob Rob have been over
that I can't bend over but as soon as
you bend over that back is connected to
the shorts that holding assist are right
that's what happens to girls like with
whenever I wear rompers because
everybody bend over - they like rides on
- I wish I wish they had a pants option
so you want to jump yeah I want to do
sustainable yeah because of the the
short like length I think it would look
better if they change the length of the
but you know what the fashion nowadays
the past version would just be joggers
at the bottom so an unlike the jumps to
us nice and baggy and loose there'll be
like a crazy like Metro cutters with
joggers at the bottom I like short
shorts now what is your definition of
short shorts like [ __ ] 1970s
basketball shorts like your
you've also Papa yeah oh that is very
short it's not a James Bond movie
yeah see that's to show my robber yeah
see like your dicks gonna come out of
that immediate map me mine gets
shriveled when I work out so I don't
want to be there I realized that the
shorter my shorts the more flexibility
and breathing and I feel free
so back like back in a day was cool to
have shorts that were more like capris
for that remember those shorts like the
basketball shorts now I mean they still
have them in basketball shorts where
it's like super baggy goes past the knee
but then they're kind of hard to kick in
and stuff they and then your range of
motion it like gets tight when you kind
of spread too much but then now I like
pretty much if I could I [ __ ] do it
naked or wispy does yeah maybe speedos
because I don't want my dick jangling
out all over the place like it by itself
like peer selected are you gonna get
some sales and just go to the line feel
maybe if it doesn't bother people around
me how's it going guys don't forget to
like the video because if you don't I
will break your [ __ ] legs thank you
so much for the last videos don't forget
to click right here or I'll break your
[ __ ] arms click right here guys
[Music]